nueve hombres y diez mujeres conforman
este nuevo gabinete de manuel macro ni
de su primera ministra elisabeth von que
acaba de ser anunciado aquí en el
palacio del elíseo entre los
nombramientos varias caras conocidas
varias confirmaciones entre ellos el
ministro de economía bruno le maire que
por cierto fue el primero en ser
mencionado eso quiere decir que es el
ministro más importante pues la
importancia está dada en el orden de
esta lista en el segundo lugar el
ministro de interior
a mano también confirmado en su cargo la
primera cara nueva llega en el tercer
lugar de parte de katrin colom a ella es
actualmente el embajador en el reino
unido en nombrada ministra de exteriores
y asuntos europeos y en cuarto lugar
otro conocido el ministro de justicia
confirmado en el cargo de rick dupont
moretti entre las caras nuevas la que
más llama la atención el de bab and die
él es el nuevo ministro de educación
actualmente es director del museo de
inmigración a de parís un profesor
universitario se cree que su
nombramiento justamente busca acercar el
gobierno a los profesores y también otra
cara nueva en cultura
abdul málek ella es la consejera cultura
de manuel macro y es la creadora del
pase cultura de este quinquenio que
acaba de terminar si no llama la
atención cómo han cambiado los nombres
de algunos ministerios quizás en
consideración de las crisis que vivió el
gobierno de manuel macro en su primer
quinquenio por ejemplo el ministerio de
economía también se llama de soberanía
industrial nos hace pensar en la crisis
del cob y 19 también el ministerio de
salud que se llama de prevención también
pensamos en la crisis de las mascarillas
el ministerio de agricultura es de
soberanía alimentaria y nos hace también
recordar la crisis en ucrania y la
crisis que hemos tenido justamente de la
agricultura y la alimentación en este
momento y terminamos con el ministerio
de deportes y juegos olímpicos que hace
referencia a esos juegos olímpicos que
van a tener lugar aquí en parís en el
año 2024 este nuevo gabinete se reunirá
por primera vez el lunes a las 10 de la
mañana y podría cambiar tras las
legislativas ya que varios ministros y
ministros delegados son candidatos a
esas elecciones